est-ce que vous allez vous faire
vacciner jean-luc comme mon travail tout
d'abord comme ça sera mon tour parce que
il ya plus de gens que moi deuxio quand
mon médecin me dira on fait ceci ou on
fait cela je suis plutôt en bon soldat
discipliné où les bénéfices ne pas faire
n'importe quoi ni a au nom de sa
accepter les yeux fermés n'importe quoi
est méfiant c'est pas que je suis
méfiant c'est que depuis le début cette
affaire est gérée en dépit du bon sens
c'est un set cette crise cette pandémie
très mal géré alors que nous disposons
de tant d'éléments qui permettait de
prévoir ce qui allait se passer comme la
2e la première fois ok on n'était pas au
courant bondit pris par surprise
mais quand on a commencé à dire nous il
faut penser aux déconfinement la dire
vous êtes un tireur dans le dos parce
qu'il faut pas parler de déconfinement
bon très bien du coup on a des consignes
et un peu n'importe comment
on a dit aurait une deuxième vague il ya
une deuxième bague je me suis fait
traiter de tous les noms
ensuite j'ai dit les vaccins ok vous
pouvez pas rendre sa obligatoire parce
que l'organisation mondiale de la santé
dit qu'il faut pas que ça obligatoires
moi je n'ai pas d'avis sur le sujet mais
puisqu'ils disent ah ben on va faire
comme ça ils se montrent plus plus
compétents que nous le vaccin n'est pas
obligatoire mais on doit pouvoir choisir
librement
alors on me dira monsieur mélenchon
qu'est ce que vous voulez choisir à
l'époque il y en avait quand d'axa mois
60 degrés a pas besoin est un aigle pour
comprendre que à vaccin à moi 60° la
chaîne du froid
elle va être rompu et puis surtout elle
il va se produire la chose suivante
c'est que certains pays pourront jamais
vacciner leur population ça alors il ya
que les petits actes et des gens qui
réfléchissent pas trop qui croient que
le virus lui va pas voyager si voyage
raïs il a voyagé ces scores bonté sa
totalité
non mais c'est toujours dit il comble
aime ça je reconnais pourparlers sur la
porte vous allez apprécier mon humour je
suis sûr vous ne partagerez je me suis
dit tiens pour les provoquer je vais
parler du vaccin russe et du vaccin
chinois un mauvais ça a marché comme
c'est un chiffon est ce que mélenchon
veut oui eh bien maintenant caire qui
ruinait ben oui il n'y avait pas besoin
non plus d'être très intelligent pour
arriver à comprendre que les russes sont
entrés au niveau scientifique et qu'ils
sont capables de faire un vaccin le seul
qui marche aujourd'hui par conséquent
juste un mot cyril hanouna peau de
seconde en varna plein d'idées tout sur
le sujet est bien comme moi pelé cyril
hanouna
oui mais moi je n'arrête pas de dire que
vous savez on a fait tout le long des
propositions alors reviendront peut pas
on ne peut pas nous entendre
quand en mai on leur a dit ça va mal
tourner avec les étudiants parce qu'ils
sont dans une wii pas possible c'est
magog vous cherchez votre région va pas
hésiter à ben oui mais maintenant je
vais vous dire encore autre chose il va
falloir vivre avec les amis vous ne
sortirez plus jamais des pandémies
pourquoi parce que c'est maintenant que
ça a commencé une première fois vous
avez tous compris d'où viennent les
pandémies dé la déforestation de
l'artificialisation d'une chasse les
bêtes de l'endroit où elle vivait donc
elles passent de 10 verset comme ça
depuis le début de l'humanité les
première épidémie
c'est avec les premières villes moins
4500 ans avant notre ère
mais maintenant on va dire avec première
cause deuxième chose c'est que la cause
concrète comment ça passe ça passe par
les élevages concentrationnaires on dit
hyper intensifs
la ferme des des millevaches l'élevage
du cac 40 mille cochons les 1 million de
vison autrement dit c'est un mode de
production agricole la de l'élevage qui
est un facilitateur pas d'épidémie avez
vous entendu dire depuis le début qu'on
se soit mis d'accord dans le monde pour
dire écoutez on arrête avec ces
conneries parce que c'est par là que ça
parle j'ai pas entendre on a commencé à
dire pour les visons mais un peu pâlot
on arrêtait son arrêt ne parie pas sur
les autres laurence on va vous donner la
france ne rangez vous mais bon vous avez
le droit de dire que vous aimez les
élevages contrant saturn hier pourquoi
pas vous mais moi non
alors je veux redire à cette
circonstance que dans toutes les
situations
on gagne quand on est plus humain dans
la manière d'être responsable à l'égard
des animaux et de la biodiversité est de
même aujourd'hui c'est une aberration de
passer du confinement art confinement ça
ne peut pas tenir
donc il faut confinement vous êtes vous
dit quoi vous ce que je propose
ça fait déjà deux trois mois que jambes
et tout le monde avec ça c'est quand il
dit on veut une société par roulement en
rotation vous devez organiser qu'on
puisse vivre c'est à dire que bah quand
vous allez à l'école la moitié est à
l'école l'autre moitié est en garde deux
étangs
curveiller et au travail par année
attendez travail ça va plus loin
le travail moi je dis vous pourriez
changer les horaires pourquoi tout le
monde et sur les quais du métro en même
temps ou des transports en commun c'est
à peine si l'on me le couvre-feu à 18
heures alors je sais pas qui est ce qu a
trouvé une idée pareille mais c'est
stupide parce que à toulouse ils ont
fait l'étude et ils disent on est encore
plus malades qu'avant pourquoi est ce
qu'ils sont
mandela vous avez été samedi faire
beaucoup je me suis posé moi j'ai oublié
de le faire si vous vous allez faire vos
courses nous sommes à l'oulipo je vais
pas vous dire où je vais en plus
mais oui j'essaye voudrait peut faire
les belles j'essaye de vivre de vivre
librement sur la situation et les médias
alors la question bien précise
oui je suis pour l'instant je suis pour
qu'on rouvre tout et que évidemment mais
d'énormes donc on se dire on rouvre
tournant mais jean luc ne s est pas
c'est pas c'est pas complètement cessé
pas complètement idiot davet
propositions de jean-luc on ne souhaite
pas du tarn à team parce que c'est vrai
que c'est peut-être une solution de tout
ouvrir et de dire voilà c'est comme
quand on faisait des voitures paires et
impaires
et ben voilà un nom mais c'est de
regarder vers l'assemblée nationale on a
une buvette d'accord bon alors il ya une
buvette on peut manger tout ça va comme
a encore eu comme ça on est pas obligé
de sortir d'ailleurs tous les restos
sont fermées alors le 4 août vers le
haut ça va 5 minutes et à la buvette
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils nous ont
mis à des distances réglementaires c'est
insupportable alors déjà que j'ai
tendance à parler fort ou avec parce que
vous avez l'autre il a deux mètres alors
c'est peu des conditions pour vous ça
doit pas mais ça me gêne pas mais je
préfère sa quête tout seul et puis je
vais vous dire moi ma vie elle est plus
simple que celle des autres
je vais à l'assemblée nationale je
reviens chez moi et que j'étais rage et
comme je suis député je circule comme
comme je veux mais les gens c'est pas ça
qui miment on est enfermé vous trouvez
normal je suis pour qu'on rouvre tout
avec des normes sanitaires
évidemment j'ajoute la chose suivante je
ne suis pas d'accord pour qu'on laisse
mourir
les personnes âgées tout seul malgré
suis pas c'est encore hélas dessus celui
qui veut voir du père ou sa mère quand
c'est l'heure qui s'avance vers le
moment où la lumière va s'éteindre
il a le droit à un contact humain à bas
la société humaine dans laquelle nous
vivons
alors on a juste le droit d'aller dormir
fermer sa bouche et travailler je ne
suis pas d'accord
organisons
autrement quand j'étais gamin en afrique
du nord comme je l'aï dit il était plus
pauvre que maintenant et bien au se
méfier des microbes et tout ça alors par
exemple quand on faisait les légumes on
mettait le père nantes permanganate de
potassium alors établi et violée quand
j'étais gosse mes parents d'expliquer on
met ça pour tuer les bactéries et je
sais pas quoi encore on vivait avec on
avait appris à vivre avec
on se laver les mains souvent bon donc
il faut qu'on apprenne à vivre avec
sinon on va vivre enfermé et ça ne
tiendra pas les êtres humains sont des
êtres sociaux
ce n'est pas un supplément d'âme d'aller
au cinéma d'aller au bistrot non cyril
quand on a fait les histoires de lieux
de culte mais alors huit ans gars comme
moi en train de défendre le droit
d'aller à l'église à la synagogue et à
la mosquée ben j'ai fait parce que je
leur ai dit mais vous êtes complètement
fou vous comprenez rien aux êtres
humains c'est les êtres humains sont des
êtres un grand nombre d'entre eux ont
besoin vivent avec la fois et ils ont
besoin surtout quand ça va mal c'est
surtout comme ça va mal qu'ils en ont
besoin
on perd alors on m'a regardé on a dit
dans le figaro jean muc mélenchon
suppôts de la religion non on n'a pas
fait d'accord suppôts de la religion moi
ma rue
si vous voulez les lieux où je rencontre
les gens c'est les bistrots je suis pour
les bistrots other alors pour les
bistrots choix font à la boulette
il faut se mettre en garde et comme on
est là on a tout ça on n'a pas dit à
plus d'émission ayant reconnu en
resteront dépendants les mêmes mesures
pour le lieu de culte chose que pour les
lieux de culte
c'est dur surtout à ouvrir j'en ai
théâtre parce que c'est très cinéma
aussi le théâtre c'est plus facile à
organiser
bien sûr que d'être sur le quai du métro